People tend to find it a little annoying for celebrities to be vocal about politics,...
...and I get it.
I know. I'm an actress, I'm not a world leader.
And the line of reasoning is, these bright, shiny objects get more airtime...
...not because they're more informed or they're any smarter,...
...but just because they played some badass hero in a movie,...
...and they think they know everything.
I've often been told by trolls to stick to acting...
...or to shut up because I'm a stupid celebrity.
But you know what, I don't care.
I don't care.
There's too much to fight for.
While we're distracted with pretty Instagram shots of coffee and celebrity breakups,...
...our freedoms are at risk of slipping away.